Jennifer Kent's 2014 horror hit the
babadook has plenty to say about grief
and the exhaustion of motherhood while
also being just plain scary part of the
movies appeal is it's moody ambiguous
ending if it's in a look or in a book
you can't get rid of the babadook but
you can understand it
Nevada Duke opens on Mother Amelia
experiencing the traumatic event that
underlines the entire film her husband
Oscars death in a car accident while
driving to the hospital for the birth of
their son Samuel it's easily read as a
flashback or a horrible nightmare but
it's just as fair to say that the
accident is the only event in her life
that is mattered for the past six years
when she falls onto the bed in the
opening scene it's as if those years
have only been a dream a first glimpse
of Samuel is him waking up Amelia it's a
metaphor for a theme that echoes
throughout Amelia is sleepwalking
through her days and marking the hours
until the dark times fade but she's
entirely stuck on Oscars death that
event is so intertwined with Samuels
birth that she struggles to be the
mother that he needs her to be and
unfortunately for her he's not an easy
child to raise if dealing with crippling
grief in an unruly child weren't enough
the title monster soon makes an
appearance when Samuel finds mr. Baba
Dook a book that's appeared mysteriously
on his bookshelf
although Samuel is initially excited for
Amelia to read it to him that excitement
quickly turns to fear once they begin
the book describes a horrible monster
called the babadook that invades its
victims thoughts and home and is
impossible to banish
[Music]
the babadook burrows in deep and soon
becomes a constant source of fear for
both Samuel and Amelia
Samuels behavior intensifies as he
suffers from insomnia and persistent
nightmares that the babadook is inside
the house
Amelia's own insomnia gets worse and the
fragile relationship is stretched to the
breaking point
the babadook is a potent metaphor for
all sorts of mental ailments from
postpartum depression to overwhelming
grief part of the reason that the
monster works so well as a metaphor is
that amelia doesn't have the strength to
ask for help in the literal sense it
seems like she's being attacked by a
horrible monster that's invisible and
seemingly everywhere all the time in the
metaphorical sense she's struggling with
violent urges towards her son in either
case she can't possibly ask for help and
sound remotely stable children see
monsters amelia and samuel becomes
steadily more isolated from everyone as
the babadook grows more and more
powerful whatever sleep amelia was able
to grasp before becomes non-existent
after it invades the house in terms of
visual design the babadook owes equal
influence to German Expressionism and
the work of writer artist Edward Gorey
the creature is all jagged corners and
suffused with a slick oily blackness
that blends into the walls German
Expressionism was an artistic movement
interested in exploring highly stylized
stories that often dealt with themes of
insanity and betrayal
during her insomnia fueled T V marathons
amelia watches some German expressionist
films the mr. Baba Dook book meanwhile
is strongly influenced by Gauri's thick
line work and gently misshapen figures
these references aren't just an artistic
flourish they give both Emilia and the
audience a form with which to categorize
the babadook in classic German
expressionist style the monster is both
an actual true monster and also an
imaginary visualization of Amelia's
exhaustion and mental illness Emilia and
Samuel eventually managed to defeat the
babadook by banishing it to the cellar
at this point Emilia seems more
energetic and awake than we've ever seen
her she's caring and warm towards Samuel
and harsh editing and sound mixing that
characterized Samuels temper tantrums
earlier in the film are completely gone
it seems like a happy ending and
till we see why samuel was gathering
earthworms from their garden amelia
takes the worms down to the babadook
which is still living in the cellar
it nearly attacks her but she manages to
calm it down although she's shaken when
she returns to Samuel in the backyard
it's a far cry from her earlier
experiences with the monster just as the
book repeated so insistently you can't
get rid of the babadook but it turns out
that you can live with it it's still in
the basement and it's still dangerous
but it's a thing that Amelia can live
with now that she stopped denying it the
end of the movie sees Amelia
acknowledging the babadook is a
permanent presence in her in Samuels
lives giving herself the room and time
to feed her grief lets her be awake
really awake for the first time that
we've seen in the film one of the most
important lines of dialogue comes right
before Amelia goes into the cellar to
feed the babadook
if the babadook represents the grief
that amelia feels over Oscars death then
samuel will have to eventually reckon
with it too he might not have ever known
his father enough to mourn him the way
his mom has but that grief is waiting in
the wings for when he's older this also
fits the idea that the babadook
represents mental illness as many forms
are hereditary it's likely that samuel
will one day have to battle the same
monsters figurative and literal that
amelia struggled against check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]